So I just moved in and my bedroom is in the basement.
And when we first moved in,
we saw that pole there, and I was like, hmm,
that looks interesting. I wonder what the fuck.
There's like a water pipe thing in my bedroom.
So I'm like, hm,
renters insurance is probably,
probably gonna be on the list of things to get.
Cause what if that fucking paint burst in my bedroom with all my shit?
Guess what fucking happened yesterday,
literally as I was trying to take the kid.
I babysit a kid for the summer.
His mother is blind and his father is blind,
so it's not like they could just come pick him up.
So his mom's like, hey,
we're home. Can you bring my kid home?
And I'm like, got you.
And then I hear, like,
a fucking waterfall. And I'm like,
there's nothing running. We don't have the washing machine,
we don't have the dishwashers not on.
Like, what the fuck?
And I go downstairs and I see a fucking waterfall pouring onto. Oh.
Of, like,
memories under my sonogram pictures.
Fucking my boyfriend's, all his computer shit.
I was like, oh my god.
Turned it off, went outside,
the guy, there was somebody,
like, doing, like,
yard work on our hose or whatever.
And he came in, thank god.
He was like the nicest person on the planet.
I told him
the only good thing that came from this was a restored faith.
In humanity. Cause that man,
if I had to pick between bear and man,
that man, I would pick him.
Oh, god.
So, um.
It was a bit of a fucking stressful night.
Made me kind of hate living here a little bit.
And. Yeah,
they told me that the repair man was.
I was first on his list, and he just called me.
He's like, I'll be there around 2:00.
I was like, okay,
that's great. Yeah,
you're. You're great. So
thankfully,
I'm the only one that stressed about this.
My boyfriend's like, it's okay.
My kids are like, we're home with mommy, so.
But that's a little update on moving in.
It's been stressful as fuck.
And that water thing really. It really upset me.